[Music]
now here's how our jobs are different on
my show they do everything they can to
get me to keep my shirt on on your show
it seems that the creators are
constantly trying to think of scenarios
where they dent your shirt off sure yeah
and I and and for example they came up
with a scene where you're just being
your chest is being licked by kittens
yeah it how do they justify that I don't
know that they they they did to be quite
honest with you I asked and I said you
know oddly enough this doesn't drive the
story at all why are we doing this and
they thought well we think it's gonna be
funny and I call okay you know what
great right and I kind of had some pride
in myself and that the first couple
seasons I was like hey man I'll do
whatever you guys asked loved this job
grateful yeah and then you know I did
that
and my father watched the show and my
father who's like so proud of me cannot
believe any of this is happening after
having like struggled for like you know
a good 10 years yeah all of a sudden
this great success with a new girl every
minute he's just like he'll call me and
but can you believe this is happening
and then he watched me getting my
nipples licked by a kid and he called me
and he goes yeah yeah that wasn't funny
and I thought oh my god that was you
know that's a regret that I regret I'll
have it man we have a photo let's make
sure your dad sees this there you go
here's just on a hay bale well you know
that doesn't make sense at all and I'm
not really quite sure like why I'm
wearing a cowboy hat you were in the
show what do you mean you don't know why
I still don't know